hey guys dr. Berg here now last week I
did a video on how to eat bacon to burn
off belly fat this week we're going to
reverse the flow and teach you how to
burn fat if you are a vegan alright
we're going to use the same principle
but we're going to show you different
foods alright now I asked you a question
last time if you watch the video
what is the hormone that determines
whether you burn fat or burn sugar do
you know there is a hormone that will
determine this and I'm going to use a
reference called Guyton's medical
physiology the bible of medical
physiology used in all the medical
schools and also pre-med classes so on
page 926 here it says actually 9:27 it
says all aspects of fat metabolism are
greatly enhanced in the absence of
insulin so all fat burning is greatly
enhanced when you don't have insulin
okay now over here the role of insulin
in switching between carbohydrate and
lipid metabolism that's fat metabolism
it says right here when the glucose
concentration is low when sugar is low
insulin secretion is suppressed and fat
is utilized almost exclusively for
energy right and there's many many
references in here that talk about when
you have insulin lack when you're
lacking in Flint your body is forced to
burn fat so insulin is the main hormone
that we need to keep suppressed if we
have any chance or hope of getting into
fat-burning okay so when insulin is high
you're going to stimulate trigger when
insulin is low you're going to stimulate
fat burning all right so that's that now
you've probably heard of the glycemic
index right foods high in sugar you have
to avoid those but there's also
something else called the insulin index
okay and I'm going to show you that next
alright so now we have all the glycemic
index foods which are foods that turn
into sugar fast which trigger insulin
but there are other things that trigger
insulin too and you can see those in the
insulin index
okay which I have right here so I have
from low to high all the foods that
don't really trigger insulin and the
ones that do what I did is I summarize
all of the foods that are acceptable
that are low on the list so what's
interesting are the fatty of foods do
not trigger insulin and they're not on
the glycemic index so our goal is to
lower insulin forget about calories
let's just talk about hormones we need
to keep insulin as low as possible if
you're going to have any chance of
losing weight so these are the foods
that are acceptable to consume olives
very low on the list 3% that's really
low
avocados very low in list chia seeds
nearly zero effect pecans you can do
macadamia nuts even peanuts are low on
the list walnuts are low on the list but
keep pecans are the lowest and we have
coconut oil and coconut meat very low in
the list
mushrooms low on the list seeds
sunflower seeds pumpkin seeds are really
really good peanut butter tahini butter
that's a sesame seed butter you can get
that at the grocery store all brand now
I don't really recommend service but all
brands low on the list it's a fiber
chickpeas as hummus kidney beans are low
on the list other beans are very high in
the list in fact baked beans is nearly
up like it's a hundred percent it's way
way out of the range Oh meal steel-cut
is like a moderate so you could probably
do that occasionally tofu is low on the
list but what's interesting is highly
concentrated protein like whey protein
which is not vegan and especially soy
protein isolates you want to stay away
from that because that's very high in
the list I'll talk about in that in the
next section vegetables we can eat all
the vegetables except corn and anything
to sweet pea protein is fine and ghee
even though that comes from an animal
sometimes that's acceptable in a vegan
diet so these are the foods that you
would want to consume now these are the
foods that we want to avoid because they
do trigger insulin and some of these
glucose okay so fruits we want to avoid
all fruits grains that includes breads
pasta cereal crackers biscuits waffles
pancakes juices of all kind especially
the orange juice beans unless it's the
kidney bean or the chickpea okay and
lentils we want to avoid that's that's a
little bit higher in the list
unfortunately berries we want to avoid
potatoes and rice we want to avoid even
brown rice is quite high all sugars of
course and corn all right and then we
want to also avoid any concentrated
protein like the soy protein isolates
now you could probably do if you're
doing tofu it has to be organic or else
it's GML okay so these are the foods you
want to consume these are the foods you
want to avoid now there's a couple other
principles the other thing that triggers
insulin index is gastrointestinal
hormones so every time you eat you
virtually trigger insulin to some degree
so what got you in this position in the
first place is just maybe too much
snacking eating the wrong foods and just
the stimulation of insulin whether
you're a diabetic or not many people
that have belly fat are it's called
insulin resistance which basically are
pre-diabetic which they have a messed up
insulin and they need to actually fix it
so what we want to do we got breakfast
lunch and dinner what we want to avoid
are the snacks in between why because
eating a meal triggers insulin so we
want to start off with three meals a day
now even though the insulin is spiked if
you don't need to have anything between
the male will have a chance for your
switch to start switching more to
fat-burning okay and especially at night
now if you're not hungry in the morning
then don't eat so therefore we have two
meals lunch and dinner and what will
happen when you're not eating you can
burn fat longer because the meal that we
want to have your body consume is your
own belly as the meal as the food and we
want to switch over to fat-burning and
then eating now here's the
problem if you can't go from one meal to
the next without starving without
needing a snack what we're going to do
is we're going to add more fat maybe
some olives to the meal the next meal we
keep adding fat to the next meal until
we can go longer longer the fat is not
necessarily going to help you burn fat
but it's low on the insulin scale and it
allows the it allows you not to
stimulate insulin it allows you to go
longer coconut oil avocado pecans we
want to add a little more fat to the
meal for the purpose of going longer so
you can do a little intermittent fasting
which also greatly improves insulin
resistance okay
versus a low calorie grazing all-day
starvation that will not work because we
have never a chance to induce the the
fat burning effect okay so we want to
eat these foods avoid these foods have
less frequent meal no snacking try to
get a little bit more sleep we add
exercise that would be cool and then
also add apple cider vinegar 2
tablespoons in a glass of water with
each meal okay so those actions I think
will help you more than anything else
so go ahead apply this and give me some
comments below I will see you in the
next video hey thanks for watching
listen I'm always trying to come up with
new ideas for new videos but I just
wanted to ask you personally what do you
need help with so if there's any topic
or subject that you'd be more interested
in please click the link below and let
me know thank you very much